he is angle of elevation well elevations
like if you're facing like horizontally
like this and you're elevating or you're
looking up okay so to your line of sight
so if you were to draw this angle of
elevation would look like this so it's
up from the horizontal now say for
example if you're like this looking
straight out and you're looking down
that's angled depression like if you're
depressed you know you lower your Euler
your line of sight right so depressions
down from the horizontal that's gonna
look like this okay now in a lot of
these problems angle of elevation or
angle depression what I recommend for
students is just think of a rectangle
like this okay if you're looking let's
just say like this draw that diagonal so
elevation is up from the horizontal
angle of depression is down from the
horizontal but what you'll notice is
that these two angles are actually
congruent to each other they're called
alternate interior angles so if you
remember when you learned about parallel
lines right cut by a transversal see
this third line it cuts across see these
are an interior ones on the right ones
on the left side of the transversal
those are alternate interior they're
congruent also because it's a rectangle
these sides are going to be the same and
these sides are going to be the same so
you can think of every problem in that
that fashion like this but let's get
into an example and I'll show you so a
10-foot ladder leans against a building
with an angle of elevation of 48 degrees
how high up the wall does the ladder
reach okay so let's just say this is our
building here right okay and here's the
ground here and here's the ladder like
this okay and so angle validation up
from the horizontal that's going to be
your elevating okay 48 degrees this is a
right angle and this is how high up it
reaches and the ladder is 10 feet tall
so what you want to do is you want to
figure out like what trig function ties
together this angle this side and this
side well you can see we have opposite
and hypotenuse that's the sine so we've
got sine of 48 degrees equals opposite
over hypotenuse and then what we can do
is multiply both sides by 10 to get H by
itself and we've got it so let's go to
the calculator let's see what that is so
let's see here we've got 10 times the
sine of 48 so it's about 7 point 4 feet
that's how high up its reach
right there so 7.4 feet
so again angle of elevation angle of
depression problems one other thing I
just mention is like say for example
there was somebody you know in this
building okay right here let's say
they're looking out this from this ledge
right here and if you extend out like
that they're going to be looking down
okay over here like at this person at
the base of the ladder right these two
angles are alternate interior angles and
they're going to be equal to one another
so 48 degrees this would also be 48
degrees so I hope this helped you
understand how to work with angle
elevation and angle of depression
problems better subscribe to the channel
check out more math tutoring videos on
my youtube channel
mario's math tutoring and I look forward
to helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon